[Applaudissements]
dans l'esprit
[Musique]
alors alex
votre sentiment coupable
m si je pense qu'il peut faire danser
avec les stars ah oui c'est vrai avant
la
stella calais on va enchaîner avec
vraiment mais bon et pourtant j'ai
regardé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
[Applaudissements]
ce
[Rires]
que j'aimais chez vous parce que j'aime
et c'est l'eau
en boîte
regardez tout de suite
j'ai adoré mon je n'ai jamais vu dans
celle je connais depuis des années a dit
hier mais
il fait rire l'horaire saint ferréol
hors alimentaire des abeilles mais non
mais c'est vrai quand même si copa temps
il rajoute des couleurs aux couleurs de
l'arc-en-ciel merci à très riche et très
honoré d'accord merci pour l'instant au
niveau de la danse vous mettez qui en
tête pour le moment c'est à l'égalité
soit dans le garder d'accord pas ce
petit là avec moi
légende 2 étages sans savoir jugez-vous
foulée 3 c'est parti à l'écran le
nouveau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du conte dansé en pyjama
et rendirent et l'ado rien de mettre
dans sa chambre et on vient
c'est jacques
[Rires]
hamel sans déconner est là c'est un truc
de fou alors tu vas dans c'est comme ça
wheller à nice déjà au niveau de la
tenue est ce que ça peut te dire non
voilà il est déjà prêt c'est chantal
reeves et sean tout voilà là bas on voit
qu'il ya maintenant dans la mode on voit
qu'elle est
tout à fait pas chaud pour demain c'est
vrai c'est joli moment arrête t ne râle
pas ils s'en sont bien
d'accord liant la fois c'est pas le lien
intentions si
je vois mais j'ai même en noir
exactement c'est fou et vous vous avez
pris le truc ah oui c'est bien celui-là
il magnifie pour descendre les poubelles
[Rires]
allez-y
à
[Musique]
ah ah
et bien croyez qu'ils avaient une marina
et je te longue abaya quoi inviter
[Rires]
à quel moment tu te dis je vais faire
cette danse ça mais c'est un nouveau
concept ces créatures aux etats unis
c'est un bide en semi parade nuptiale
laura 10 y est tu sais qu'il ya une
règle d'or dans cette émission toutes
les personnes qui intègrent l'équipe
doivent donc si même un petit peu ouais
mais juste une petite danse de 2 15
secondes c'est juste pour le voilà c'est
un peu l'intégration et voilà c'est un
petit peu le week-end d'intégration
de l'intégration s'est tu ne peux pas la
faire je comprendrais tout à fait et je
ne te jetterai pas la pierre je danse
très très mal alors moi justement tu va
la faire
m mes sympathies mouvement va laisser
partir des mots remercie
[Applaudissements]
à
je
me suis jamais tenir aux règles il ya
une vraie je sais c'est quoi la pente ou
là comme au niveau danseurs
c'est comme quand les karatékas les
judokas tu dit je ne peux pas me battre
en dehors du tatami par mois et primes
de match on apprend donc je ne peux pas
penser en dehors d'une piste homologuée
aujourd'hui pour le sema le corps et
donc non je veux d'avoir réellement seul
et après éventuellement bien entendu on
n'ira jamais à coachella pour l'instant
allez-y dans alice prenez votre destin
entre vos mains alors c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le rallye sans fait atterrir à la main
ça déconne et ce but mais j'avais envie
de me tuer quatre de front la météo
alors
abattu